[Musique]
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais c'est
ouais
bonjour monsieur excusez moi de vous
déranger je pense que vous connaissez
les produits double verra moi je vous
proposais n'a pas cette démo une
cassette comique avec lequel vous
passerez 40 minutes environ de joie et
de bonne humeur
alors monsieur est ce que ça vous
intéresse ben ils sont déjà passés hier
lui-même pour le je sais mais c'est un
autre produit moi c'est un produit w je
leur avais un produit jeunes un produit
moderne d'un produit dynamique
bon alors est-ce que vous m'accordez
cinq minutes commence à 00h05 monsieur g
et je vous assure vous ne serez pas
déçus c'est la petite blague quoi le
petit plus
ça peut devoir rapidement un gros mois
tiens tu sais de servir de ta ta télé
oui j'y arrive jarret je finis par y
arriver
attention je suis monsieur le mans mardi
et je peux à présent mais j'arrive de
baky et nous produisons 20 tout là bas
je peux même vous dire je connais quand
elle bouge toi qui ne trompe appartement
quand tu voudrais rien avec mathieu
hippeau dis à ta maman de ma compta
pratique surtout si elle est blonde
avant qu'un portrait on tombe tout
d'abord bonjour mesdames et messieurs
dames je profite de l'occasion qui avait
fait partie
enfin même esprit mais ne m'exprime à
vous concernant une fonction qu'il n'est
pas toujours les comics il je trouve
inadmissible que sont scindés en ce sens
elle c'est pas bien ça fait 12 ans que
je mets des bébés les judéo on n'est pas
des pestiférés on est des êtres humains
quand on dit bonjour momentanément
célibataire endurci sûr je suis c'est
évident et dans le cuissot ferme
elle ment la bière et n'étant pas choqué
par une personne physique atomique dans
le bourg et la paix il demanderait jean
patrick même chose
[Rires]
bonjour je m'appelle francis poste je
traverse actuellement une très mauvaise
passe d'ailleurs j'ai toujours à
l'enseignement des sciences marines a
quitté au bout de 14 jours
je travaille dans un domaine bien
spécifique était farces et attrapes avec
mes collègues ça se passait pas bien du
tout mais alors pas bien du tout je
cherchais un emploi stable
c'est un moyen de locomotion suis gentil
connard salut je m'appelle jean laberge
bonjour moi c'est jean-pierre gesticule
il me faisant partie de l'association
des handicapés patronymique la porte et
nous l'assumons nous a peut-être et
notre association qui se réunit tous les
mercredis après midi nous vous invitons
tous vous qui avaient des noms aussi
difficile à porter que nous à nous
rejoindre nous serons vous écoute et ne
soyez plus seul
[Rires]
je suis enfin de moi des gens d'acheter
la casse est petit dans mon cas j'ai
regardé bien sûr que si on regarde tout
la cassette on est dans la merde
peinture c'est vrai je pense que c'est
la dernière toute façon pour moi ça va
cinq minutes les petites annonces je
vais pas faire ça toute ma vie tous les
jaloux volume c'est bien oui mais bon
après j'ai une autre idée de façon il a
dit non je ne dis pas non
bref tu sais de quoi je sais ce que j'ai
ouais moi ce que je veux dire
j'ai une autre ancien mal c'est la
première ça a bien marché ouais ouais on
a vendu je crois vingt mille 20 mille
pigeons
moi j'ai une cassette pour toi là ouais
c'est bah tu vas voir
j'espère que c'est pas une cassette de
culte si c'est l'école de france ya
c'est un peu comme la suisse et l'ue ces
amateurs
ouais ouais ouais du porno amateur l'
écoute s'il n'y avait pas une caméra je
te dirais que j'aimerais bien l'avoir
mais là franchement non c'est un petit
peu choquant quand même l'école de l'été
c'est pas compliqué les premiers cours
la double annales ouais c'est la
nouvelle céline qui reçoit des beats en
même temps s'il est un bon c'est pas
dans cette basse et pas mal tu peux pas
regarder je m'en doute mais enfin l'été
en version originale non mais c'est son
direct ci sont virés deuxième tour elles
sont très timides les petits de la pin
non il est acculé côte à côte avec la
superbe
je suis très fier de montrer ça
t'intéresse plutôt sa maman tu peux
faire franchement je suis préfère
rigoler plutôt que demander si précis je
bande
ça va me servir à quoi là dans
l'immédiat j'avais 13 ans alors que si
j'arrive à ça dit que je préfère la
collection de certaines filles sont
perverses et se retrouve plus nous
sommes aussi non pour elle et la rentrée
des classes est un grand jour première
ce de lyon public valérie je les connais
bien rester avec moi un sixième essai
salaire ici trop longtemps c'est cette
affaire le soleil et avec dany boon bond
à 12
l'association des déficients communes
val d'oise organise tous les ans
ça tombe bien sûr chasse après le stage
de peinture faciale ou sur papier le
sens artistique le choix des couleurs là
la sensibilité artistique de jean gagné
il assumer les choix des couleurs de
sons du coup j'ai passé un truc qui fait
ça c'est pas mal c'est un vieux beau
quelques risques à la préfète qui va
[__] des neuf ça c'est avec du dos
c'est marrant c'est un peu longuet
commence avec de dollars bien bien bien
donc là un spectacle cette avance à en
parler des grèves lui nul
roxy gérant saint-brice metteur en scène
de la troupe des verts fabienne elle
donne le 22 juillet va trouver moi-même
nous nous produisons en avignon les
pèlerins que c'est comme la vie quand
c'est par dix et cent cinquante francs
la place il n'y a pas de réduction pour
les militaires c'est dire combien on ça
dure t'inquiète pas c'est à dire vrai
qu'à passer les bombes pour ça c'est un
mec qui sait très bien où se fixe
d'ailleurs j'ai fait peur à mes enfants
enfin on a quasiment gelé n'est pas la
porte
je risque d'avant ma part rooney c'est
un visage que je m'adresse à toi tu te
blesses si tu pouvais rapidement donné
bon tu ne vas pas tout ce matin mais ça
a l'air vachement bien ouais j'ai alors
dit qu'on pourrait parler on va arrêter
ça parce que j'ai l'impression d'être un
commercial parce qu'on fait en cela
m'atteint écoute on va y aller quand
même je la regardais tu vas voir tu peux
savoir la tragédie c'est facile on les
sent les coups
ce que je vois thiriez de l'attrition un
grand jour première j'en dis non ce nom
peut pas montrer ça maintenant papa
monde au rsa non on ne peut pas montrer
ça va faire licencier
non c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible
ce qui m'étonne vais te casser c'est que
normalement il devrait être aux elle
devrait être je comprends pas qu'elle
soit là je m'adresse à temps s'il vous
plaît les gens qui regardent l'émission
de dating
regardez ça mais en tout cas nous on est
en train de se rincer l'oeil lors à
tailler une petite nana qui va là oui si
surya les réseaux non on en attend à
tenir le temps avance avant d'avancer en
fait on va chercher que ce qu'on peut
montrer attends attends on va chercher
qu'est ce qu'en ce moment là c'est un
peu le montrer ça
aussi simple c'est un peu ça c'est
possible c'est possible ça va ça va
super jacquetin jeudi avec des deschiens
ça va ça sera très bien là bas ça va
progresser très très bien que ça va bien
ça va bien ça va bien et là je suis
pressé de dire tout ses intérêts la
dépouille a l'intention invitation de la
salsa elle me rappelle que ça c'est
possible
tout ça c'est possible moi ce qui fait
que tu saches ai dit c'est que même sur
le cas ben y'a des trucs qu'on peut
montrer des trucs importants de f1 dont
on croit que son look à bon port n'en
ferai pas de d'ailleurs on va faire un
arrêt sur images pour tout voir pas été
tranquille voilà senna toi si vous ou
moi je suis bien son mari met à poil de
la bête
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la papa papa
et l'ex président
c'est un tyran tout ça c'est pas ça
s'échappe aussi je vais vous faire les
dénombrer eux
ouais alors là on l'a ce qui se passe
c'est que la personne est introduite en
touristes sont pas son orifice laginha
du kenyan porter quoi son sang c'est
qu'il ya donc dans la personne la
personne avère d'éprouver du plaisir
visiblement si son mari c'est parce
qu'il a promis de capotes et la jeune
fille à l'air contente alors je suis
regardé je continue à vous fait les
commentaires la jeune fille a l'air
d'apprécier
voilà mais ces épisodes seulement la
gêne dans des couleurs qui souvent
j'avais deux sages on dirait
[Musique]
c'est frustrant
a strasbourg de nice en amoureux à
l'origine à taji 2 il revient tchatche
et revient sur le [__] pour passer à la
télé un vous êtes vous êtes pu t'en
donne python décapotable pièce je suis
là je suis sodium à politis des
bananiers droit dtcc la noble original
normal
[Musique]
la première chanson qui t'a marqué c'est
quoi
[Musique]
il y avait aussi mais je ne connais pas
les paroles oui alors bien sûr premier
tube gigi gryce jeux ps2 ya le deuxième
c'était
une chanson y avait beaucoup de
personnes un baiser beaucoup de
personnes à draguer sauf moi parce qu'on
veut pas bézy sur sa chanson c'est ton
et je me suis rendu compte vingt ans
après que la plupart des français
pensaient que c'était la chanson d'amour
quand c'est un sens politique à l'égard
des courbettes like dix reprises
[Musique]
des chapeaux
maintenant
c'est bien c'est l'épreuve quoi est le
plus gros succès comme tu me le faire
mais je peux pas non banques melon parce
que c'est un truc studio qui fait essaye
nash peux pas c'est impossible je peux
le dire mais je peux aussi le bancor au
quai des marques bon la seule chanson
que tu sais jouer
parker du début à la fin comme il faut
oh
depuis ta chanson d'amour toi wells en
santé
[Musique]
mais apple a nommé m
voilà matthew camarades et chaud du
petit mas au pochoir
[Musique]
du mois mais si demain tout le paquet
à madagascar
[Musique]
la bagarre
je risque de casse
je veux dire si tu te dire
la casse
[Musique]
peux tu joues tu me lâches
si des vosges est c'est de venir
bofa
[Musique]
je jour
gas gas spa
[Musique]
brisée
deux gars je t'aime
c'est quoi ces civils est vide c'est la
barrière du ca bidon qu'est ce qu'il y
avait dedans avant sa saisie l'abus hier
à sète et de la guerre ici dit la bière
je juge a acheté avant c'est fini
non pour l'instant oui j'en paye de
l'eau et vous allez voir quoi après
après la bière asa bien vous habitez au
du mois oui je la roue qu avant ouais ça
pour ça et vous venez d'où qui moi la
route que la route que la route je suis
pas là depuis combien de temps le mois
et intelligence avant toujours la route
on essayait d'ouvrir ma loge
branchements ouais quand je maniant la
ouais je traverse la ruche pour le
schéma ouais ça va pas ça ça va oui ça
va bien vous êtes heureux tu m'as au
choix 10 et 11 ans
on
oh
elle
on
et bonsoir bienvenue
karzaï bon je suis un gars
je suis étonnée qu'elle se croquer c'est
un petit bar à se dire de plus
oui je suis dingue dingue dingue ce
vaste blague
je suis nato totaux de ceux qui seront
pas notées la musique que tu te dis que
c'est
digitimes paulo près de propriano le
royaume des projecteurs
[Musique]
cette mise en garde au fait que je dise
impressionnante que mcaleese vous en
pénétrer le coeur dans l'espoir pour
chaque chanson de chauffage ou sous
forme de symboles
on trouve parmi les stars du music hall
wade faut augmenter sa vie de garçon je
ne prolonge dans un micro un trader
moi je
je suis un gamer
seth rogen c'est là qu'il a rendu 4
obligé d'y aller car oui je suis là
[Musique]
m
le petit génie cependant
qu'on soit devant dieu
précisément que vous bien non
comme certains choix du tournant comme
un lion
amy anti déprime ne sachant plus vers
quel endroit porter tes fesses
ton studio vers pas content à des souris
sur les réseaux est un peu je me dis
tout pour effacer un seul tarif de faire
tout ça comme une brute
[Musique]
suzanne au troquet génial
tout autant de ceux qui seront à quai la
musique
concert doit être aussi
[Musique]
10 gbe la cave
tous ok
petite roue libre
risque
[Musique]
gentil qu'on doit aussi pour
le piano
[Musique]
alors un petit medley avec jean petit a
pris leur époque où des choses un petit
mètre un petit medley on peut faire les
garçons mon légionnaire et voilà le vrai
mais est-ce qu'on peut tout rentrait je
ne connais pas ces experts
on voit pas trop sage ça c'est a vu ça
c'est quand même ça lui fait un choc
tous les soirs tu peux enfin le pauvre
jean philippe souffle oui tous les soirs
alors on va vous faire aimer nos âmes et
les quelque chose de non lieu un sujet
qu'on aime bien
oui nous échec de couy cher que coûte
cher surtout 100 km messieurs les
garçons sur toutes les coutures
enfin la journée ils ont coutume ainsi
avoir en commun voilà ce qu'il ya de
meilleur
we can
koba
blanc
[Musique]
à chaque seconde en deux et chagrin
quand on possède un tronc commun
attention
[Musique]
barbant tuchan
je vais toujours le je vais bien je ne
sais quoi je m'en suis dans la nuit je
charge à tout lire mais c'est plus fort
que moi je ne peux des jurés aient fait
mal je n'ai pas un moment
je n'oublierai jamais
nous des caves assénait de tri nuit tous
les jours un délice
la belle isa d'amour
ap
dans une
je suis
alain jocard
oh
je l' ai tellement dans la cour j'en
suis partout des crimes atroces a fini
je suis à lui causer cieux sûrement
suppose outre
auzat
passons dans je ne sais
il met toute la nuit bon les lionnes
[Musique]
j'ai étudié le tube en laissant à
mandeure
ah ah
[Musique]
il était beau il sentait bon le sable
chaud
bon les jolies
[Musique]
retournez à marne-la-vallée dans besoin
d'eux pour le sang allez-y rennes
prenait ça
jours
s'étendre
m
[Musique]
dans ses bras
enchantée
[Musique]
johnny qui n'est pas un an je ne crois
pas que ça me dérange
jour et nuit je pense à toi toi qui te
souviens quand elle même du bonheur je
mets un johnny tu n'es pas un homme que
je t'aime que je t'aime
tél
je t'aime que je t'aime que tout est
fini mais tant pis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cuba
[Musique]
avant
pour les télécharger le mérite or avec
plaisir pour l'histoire des solutions
d'iron man 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
talât
chicoutimi coquette je sais que mes de
l'antonnière j'en ai comme il se doit
pour jouer du bach abandon du mézenc
bolt a raconté france exemple des
chinois et de mac entre québécois qui
sera vaincu
viva cuba et bim
ha ha en perdant d'y aller ça va mais
qu'est ce que tu fais ici tu cherches un
garçon quoi je filme le garçon a tout
filmé garçon né tu es mort regarder plus
tard chez toi alors ça c'est génial
oh moi j'étais en train de pisser contre
le mur la vérité oui et puis qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire ce soir je fais pas ta
pas trouvé quelque chose de non non non
ça ce n'est pas pour voir nadal et
gigolo les choses qu'on ne sabre à
quelqu'un plus digne et plus âgés avec
un peu d'argent qui veut ps est plus
honorable je trouve fou et qui savent
utiliser souvent paris non non non je
vive à new york et je suis ici parce que
je livre qui sort si tôt oui c'est un
roman qui concerne les travaux l'eau les
[__] les gens drogués d'aidé 42e rue
baisse est plutôt sur le sujet de la
misère aux états unis et le croisement
des bourgeois avec les gens on a misé
arables pour râler le business de
plaisir c'est un peu ça reste entraîné
comme un autour de la 42e résidents oui
moi papa beaucoup maintenant parce que
disent ni d'ici ni à acheter la 42e rue
est
ils vont à changer à 42e
il veut faire l'on doit pour les
familles les hôtels pour les touristes
et que ça mais nous tous mes potes sont
arrêtés ils sont poussés à man à la aux
autres coins oui vivons ou après je sais
pas je pense dans la banlieue sont
dispersés peu compris maintenant c'est
un peu morne
il ya sûrement cette classe moyenne tous
les gens sont là même c'est pour les
familles et c'est tout et tu seras
content toxico
qu'est ce que je raconte je reprends
c'est une histoire à deux jeunes gens
dragué qui est prostituée qui essaie de
changer son état et 2 réussis dont la
vie mais
à ce titre je dis pas la fin qu'est ce
qui est plus choquant tant qu est ce que
le plus choquant je pense à le plus cher
quand ce sont des bourgeois qui sont
fous de tous ces gens misérables
ouais tiens tu es devenu impulstar dans
ce milieu un peu interlope à new york
non merci alors j'en parle avec qui
réalise en charge des cultes un peu non
que l'homme a par yoann yoyo non mais tu
as un peu comme ce qu'a pu être selby ya
quelques années n'ont toujours pas à
jesper selby c'est mon idole alors c'est
un peu l'impression qu'on a quand on dit
on livre à merci beaucoup et oui oui non
mais aux états unis à des gens posent à
huy qu'est ce qui a trait à ça c'est mon
goryl vient du coeur est féroce et
féroce ouais ouais
et vous le protéger comme en faisant
d'eux des arts martiaux non issus de
griffes avoir besoin et à la moto et
j'ai pas d'un coup pris comme ça tu peux
les sortir un peu et vous habitez à
paris aux nues avons entre les deux
entre les deux communes mais toi tu
traduis tu traduis solaire sens c'est
vrai oui oui je suis quelqu un peu
ambigu parce que je traduis sollers et
j'ai traduit guyotat et tous les maîtres
français mais en même temps je suis un
peu paumé
un peu des deux je n'avais alors un
poète maudit vitesse et puis quoi
qu'est ce que tu vas faire là ce soir ce
soir je voulais tourner avec toi si tu
as un peu d'argent et d'être on peut
visiter des autres on doit on m'a dit
que vous voulez visiter un bar de
partout ça m'intéresse beaucoup
ouais ouais est ce que tu crois que tu
vas continuer longtemps comme ça
longtemps
comment pourriez pour l'écrit comme ça
oui à écrire comme ça oui est ce que tu
écris ça parce que tu vis comme ça où
est ce que tu dis comme ça pour écrire
ça mais pour dire la vérité maintenant
je suis un maintenant que je suis un peu
plus âgé je suis un peu plus philosophe
c'est devenu quelque chose politique je
ne traîne pas quand comme auparavant et
j'écris plus âgé des amis qu'on y sort
de prison il ira chez moi je suis je
fais des choses plutôt politique des
essais des articles pour les journaux je
suis un peu plus calme un peu moi un peu
moins dégueulasse qui tue et à qui tu es
maintenu à qui tu vois qui est ce que je
vois à new york
j'ai des amis littéraire jordana scoop
assez de bons amis de moi j'adore ce qui
est écrit
il ya d autres genres aussi j'ai des
potes qui étaient au 42ème rue et aussi
j'ai un fils adopté qui j'ai trouvé à
l'âge de 14 ans dans une norme est donc
il était son toit il dormait dans un
cinéma de porno tout le temps fait il
est venu chez moi je l'avais il a cessé
de prendre les drogues elle est devenue
à duke et maintenant c'est un bourgeois
france un bon ouais à paris ils se
demandent comment tu trouves paris quand
tu donnes ainsi que ce tarif vous
j'adore paris j'adore les parisiennes
mais en même temps paris a changé
beaucoup c'est plutôt c'est comme new
york a changé parce que paris maintenant
et tout est le même tous et pour la même
classe on ne peut pas trouver les vieux
coin
ah le quartier latin où je t'ai il y a
quinze ans c'était un peu louche
maintenant c'est plutôt ristic un peu
plus fort c'est comme new york aussi et
ça c'est un peu triste un peu morne pour
moi c'est qu'une seule chose qui choque
la seule chose qu'il fait froid
alors la seule chose qui me choque ce
sont le ce sont les gens qui n'aura
aucune aucune idée de la vie des autres
d autres classiques qui sont foot ça et
qui pense que tous les gens sont comme
comme heures je pensais ça c'est
choquant ça oui ça c'est choquant pour
moi que tu te balades entre les
différents où elle a joué
oui je sais pas c'est peut-être je pense
que je flâne ne sais pas mais en même
temps pas il ya un équilibre entre
quelqu'un qui est perdu dans ce milieu
c'est possible avec les drogues est
quelqu'un qui est complètement voyeur et
alors j'essaie de faire de faire un
mignon entre les deux mais c'est pas
possible tout le temps mais ça marche de
temps en temps tu veux ni van riebeeck a
déjà pris du crack toi moi est-ce que
j'ai pris oui j'ai pris il ya dix ans à
pendant six mois avant que les journaux
envie que c'était henry ou blur moi mais
j'essaie c'est son problème et
maintenant je bois l'alcool c'est tout
c'est tout ouais les pétards de temps en
temps quand même 20 de temps en temps
mais il balaie l on dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sinon c'est la fête
oui moi je
c'est vrai que les gens ont un peu marre
des des boîtes ont fait que danser
il ya bien les boîtes on peut danser et
baissé aussi
voilà 41 on peut danser et baisser et ce
n'est pas seulement la belle et la bête
je ne sais si toi tu veux je crée des
situations en tunisie
l institut
quoi alors m
c'est pas bien qu'avec tous
je
[Musique]
faux
lui sa femme ici
c'est sur la paire pour ça non tu as
quel âge tu fais dans la vie active
ménard et vente
[Musique]
à
tu viens ici quand même à marseille
jasinsky sort
[Musique]
très bien il
elle attend sur nous
norton se marier l'amour
[Rires]
elle adore les postures non j'étais
quand même
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est là
on éloigne les enfants du poste et
certains parents aussi
c'est ta façon de marseille n'a pas pu
souffrir d'entraînement casseurs et vous
portez bien sévère par la fenêtre de sa
chambre
suis je venais pour tout le monde
ces données
les uns
demain paul bezes mois bratton
l'enterrement
avec cette oreille
un chat
nous t'aimons
[Musique]
m
et
on ne rien rater de winne a l'habitude
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu